foreign
let's go out to the 512 in Austin and
talk to Lindsay hey Lindsay what's up
hey Dr John how are you partying what
are you up to
not much um I listened to your show like
every single day and I believe seriously
I always hear you
um say to choose guilt over resentment
every time and my question is what if I
choose guilt over resentment and then my
spouse resents me later for it
roll that
and I hate that for you
what is your what is your spouse
presenting you over
um not yet but I'm like worried that it
will happen
you're pretty worrying about future
potential resentment
yes
love it that's not anxious at all okay
so why are you pre-wiring about
potential future resentment
um okay I'll give you an example
um that we have so my husband and I come
from like really different backgrounds
culturally and
um we just we have a different family
Dynamics
so he would ideally like to see his
family a lot more than I would
um and you know I've offered like why
don't you go by yourself that type of
thing but it always turns out like he
wants me to come with we have a
one-year-old daughter and so he also
thinks it's like important for her to be
around his family and stuff like that
um
and so I've been really honest with him
like I'm not comfortable you know taking
as many trips down to see your family as
you would like to but you know we can
Compromise type of thing and we've been
working with a therapist and I will say
like he has been really good the last
time we went down there about
um changing the way the trip looks and
kind of catering to my needs more and
stuff like that but um I guess I'm just
worried that down the line like
obviously the inevitable will happen and
like family members will pass away and
like things like that and I just don't
want him to come back and say like we
should have spent more time with them
and it's your fault that we didn't
does he have a really overbearing mom
I would say they had
he was definitely raised by like an
emotionally immature mother yes okay
okay so when y'all go down to visit
do you get backseated
okay is that why you don't like to go or
is there other reasons
um unfortunately I didn't have a lot of
time to build a relationship with them
before like marriage and a baby so I do
feel like his family is like really
tight-knited and I'm kind of like the
outsider that's just like the black
sheep if you will is that a real thing
are you imagining that too
real like
kind of just like in the background
nobody really like talk to me or kind of
ask me like things about myself or makes
me feel included in the family
um it's really hard to get a word in
because they're all like really close
and
um so it just it just I'm really
uncomfortable there
I'm just trying to get to the level of
discomfort are you uncomfortable because
people aren't making overt um efforts to
include you are you uncomfortable
because they're talking about awful
things or they're disgusting and rude or
they're grabby
see what I'm saying because here's the
thing if if you are unsafe
absolutely don't go never go
um I don't it's just awkward
okay I think it's more like I've tried
to even say like can your family come up
here because obviously it's really hard
to travel with we have like almost
one-year-old so it's not convenient to
do like a three-hour road trip with a
baby sure
um and so like we've had instances where
like his mom will come here and she's
just like
I feel like she just makes comments that
are just like unnecessary you know of
course she does like she's emotionally
immature we've already established that
so it's like it's like it's like being
around a rattlesnake and you're like I
just feel like the rattlesnake just
makes noise
that's what they do that's what they do
those people you know I understood
understood and you married him
yeah so you married them
now
you get to decide whether they hurt your
feelings or not
which sounds nutty
meaning his mom is gonna be part of his
life unless she's abusive or she is
criminal or she is
insane right like whatever she's gonna
be part of his life you married into
that
and so
you get to decide what that boundary
looks like whether you're going to visit
or not visit whether you're going to be
around or whatever
but you're gonna be in each other's life
and so
when she pops off and makes all these
comments about I would never do it like
that and I don't do it like that and I
can't believe you keep your house like
this and I would be doing this and oh my
gosh that baby's gonna be so cold and
just just comments all the time
um
you get to decide whether you are
confident what you're doing
which if you have a nine or ten month
old you probably are not I didn't know
what day it was and
you get to decide whether she speaks
into your soul or not or whether she's
just this
Meandering piping old lady that is in
the house it's going to be over a couple
times a year
you see what I'm saying like there's a
it's just a
the best way I can describe it it's like
have you ever been skiing like water
skiing
so when you first get the boat takes off
and you're sitting in the water it just
is a jet blast of water to your face
and then you Crest on top of it and you
get on top of the water and really
um if you're really good like my friend
Rachel Cruz when she we go skiing out
she gets in the water and will go skiing
and then get out of the water and her
hair is perfectly dry I don't even know
how she does that she's good at it and
so you can be around those people and
they aren't going to affect you like
right okay you can make all your
comments I don't care
now if you say something offensive
around my kid I'm gonna be I'm gonna I'm
gonna speak my mind if you say something
ugly about my my spouse or my husband or
my wife whatever I'm gonna speak up
but if you're just gonna pick at my
cooking and how clean my house is and
how you can't believe it whatever so
that's that's that's that's number one
number two
at some level your husband is choosing
to shoot himself in the foot and blame
you for it
right right if he doesn't want to go see
his family or I only want to go if it's
like this perfect picture I have in my
head
well then that's on him
I don't want you to spin to waste
valuable emotional and relational energy
worrying about things that might happen
5 10 or 15 years from now
I mean you're worrying about funerals
right
now let me diffuse like here's the
fastest way I've learned to defuse that
in my own life just say it out loud
I'm uncomfortable around your family and
when you don't go I'm worried that in 10
years if one if somebody passes away
You're Gonna blame me for the lack of
time you didn't spend with them
just say it out loud
yeah it's
it's I actually told him I was gonna be
on the call and and I told him my
question I said is there anything you
want to add to this or like you know put
your two cents in and he's like that's
just a really good question and I'm like
okay
oh cause he is going to be mad at you
someday no I don't
know so sometimes
of people okay sir he had to be yeah but
I'm like are you compromising because
like
you understand and this is like what you
also want to do or are you just doing it
to like get me to shut up
does it matter for you
yeah
because that that's asking a lot
I want you to do what I say and I want
you to want to do it the way I said it
because that's you see what I'm saying
yeah
if you say I don't want you to go or I
don't want us to go
and he says all right I won't go
you can't be mad at him for grieving
that
he gets that right because he had a
picture in his head that he was gonna
have one big happy family
and he doesn't
he has a fractured family
and that's not your fault
just is
but you can't get mad at him for not
feeling the same way you feel about a
thing
that's true is that fair so if he says
no I'm going to support my wife even
when it hurts
that's pretty awesome
now if he turns around and blames you
for it later that's pretty lame because
he's making he's making grown-up choices
here's the thing
a catchphrase like choose guilt over
resentment feel so good every time it
feels so good and it feels so neatly
wrapped up in a package and it's it's so
instructive I'm just gonna do this
instead of this
when the world gets chaotic I'm gonna do
this instead of this awesome
it also is really hard
and you can only choose your guilt and
if somebody chooses to resent you you
can't do anything about that unless you
want to go run be a people pleaser at
which point you're going to end up in a
cycle of resentment
so if somebody chooses to not be in
relationship with you it hurts grieve it
and you can get on about your day
and go figure out what happens next
I do want you to spend some time
personally
asking yourself
is the things that are happening when
you visit the family
are they cultural differences
are they Outsider differences are they
purposely excluding you
because if it's cultural differences and
they're trying to honor you and the best
way they know to honor you is to not
offend you or not be weird around you so
they're just gonna try to Love You by
circling the wagons
then maybe you go learn some stuff about
this culture maybe you go take some
classes or learn some language whatever
the thing is I don't know what what the
culture is I don't even know anything
but maybe you make an effort to lean in
or if they're ugly people they just
don't want you around they're pissed off
at their their your husband for marrying
you and creating a family with you
then y'all got to create an ALT Universe
you have to create another world because
they are opting out of relationship with
you
and their grandkid and their child
and that hurts man it's hard
but I'll tell you as a guy who spent a
big chunk of my adult life in anxious
mess
worrying and spinning up today about
things that may happen 5 10 15 20 years
from now is in complete and utter waste
of your life don't do it
I lost years
of beautiful moments in the present
freaking out about things that may never
happen
and if they do okay I'll deal with them
when they happen
but live your life now
continue to be honest with your husband
and remember your mother-in-law doesn't
get a vote she doesn't get a vote
and you get to decide what happens next
um marriage is hard